c'est la petite phrase qui met le feu
aux poudres cours d'un entretien avec
les lecteurs du parisien aujourd'hui en
france emmanuel macron explicite sa
stratégie face au virus ils défendent
pas sanitaire explique qu'il serait
impossible concrètement de rendre le
vaccin obligatoire et il justifie la
pression mise sur les français n'ont
vacciné je le cite j'ai très envie de
les emmerder on va continuer de le faire
jusqu'au bout c'est ça la stratégie
bonjour marc fesneau bonjour marc
fauvelle ministre en charge des
relations avec le parlement est ce que
vous aussi de bon matin vous avez envie
d'en perdre et les cinq millions de
français non vaccinés le 2 de bon matin
j'ai envie de dire on à 271 me carrère
et qu'on a besoin que les non vaccinés
entend le message que le renvoi le
gouvernement le parlement la plupart des
parlementaires d'ailleurs le président
de la république et que l'on renvoie
aussi les français qui sont vaccinés qui
est celui de la responsabilité
le président de choisy du verdon une
formule un peu chocs effectivement de
dire des choses qui sont des choses
importantes la vérité c'est que aux
urgences et encore plus en réanimation
on a des personnes qui sont non vaccinés
que c'est ça qui vient engorgé des
services de réanimation que c'est ça qui
fait aussi qu'on est obligé de
déprogrammer un certain nombre
d'opérations il ya un appel à la
responsabilité qui doit écrits et ses
prêts pour la seule instance habilitée
est-ce que ça se fait avec ces mots là
où est ce que vous pensez pas que ça va
aussi les vracs est plutôt que de le
nain dans les premières années je
rappelle que le président de la
république la première fois s'est
exprimé sur les questions vaccinale non
pas dans le process vaccinale parce que
c'était il ya plus d'un an désormais
mais au mois de juillet dernier pour
dire qu'il fallait qu'on aille vers
quelque chose qui soit plus de
contraintes à ceux qui n'étaient pas
vaccinés c'est une stratégie qui est
assumée depuis le début c'est une
stratégie française qui n'est pas une
stratégie vous l'avez rappelé
l'obligation vaccinale parce que ça n'a
pas d'intérêt parce qu'on ne peut pas
l'appliquer la vérité vaut bien tout
faire on va pas emprisonner les gens
comme le président l'a publiquement va
pas leur donner auprès des gens modestes
et surtout à des gens modestes amendes
de 1000 à 2000 euros il a raison de dire
ça mais simplement il faut que les gens
se vaccine on a maintenant un recul
plusieurs milliards de citoyens du monde
ont été vaccinées il ya un recul y
compris scientifiques puisque c'était le
gars l'argument qu'on nous oppose et
bien non on ne me posait un autre qui
était quand même que les données
scientifiques étaient bonnes et c'est ça
qui vient mettre en danger ceux qui ne
sont pas vaccinés d'abord et c'est à
vous je pense et aux drames familiaux
qu'on a on a encore eu des les
personnalités célèbres cette semaine et
l'on vient trois responsables il ya
trois semaines et maintenant dans
l'interview qu'il a donnée à tf1
promettait de ne plus blessé les
français ce sont des mots pour vous ce
mot là en particulier qui ne blessent
pas moi je vais vous dire je vois bien
que ça produit un électrochoc pour
certains si c'est ça qui est sur la
table moi je trouve que c'est salvateur
mais chacun le dit avec les mots qui
veut peut importe chacun à son
vocabulaire mais je dis moi je veux dire
ce qui me blesse ce qui me plaît c'est
de voir que depuis plus d'un an on est
sur une stratégie vaccinale qui s'avère
payante pour ceux qui l'ont suivi et ses
92 % des français et quand vous vous
êtes comme vous et moi à croiser des
français tous les jours qu'ils vous
disent quand même un moment la
contrainte elle pèse sur tout le monde
alors qu'il faudrait que ceux qui ne
sont pas vaccinés prennent leur part de
responsabilité donc c'est ça qu'il faut
faire parce que c'est leur intérêt à eux
d'abord et donc c'est ça qui est
important c'est propos d' emmanuel
macron provoquer une nouvelle suspension
des débats à l'assemblée du cool parce
vaccinale n'est toujours pas adopté les
oppositions demande la présence
immédiate papa 7h14 du matin la présence
immédiate aujourd'hui de jean castex
principe hier c'était à une heure du
matin c'est à une heure du matin après
est-ce qu'il va venir tout d'abord le
premier ministre s'est expliqué devant
l'assemblée pour permettre la reprise
des débats non mais il y avait deux
ministres vers angers était aux côtés du
ministre et rend le pot ministre il
viendra si du juge opportun de venir
dans ces débats simplement il a dit un
certain nombre des choses hier aux
questions gouvernement je pense pas que
ce soit son rôle de répondre aux oukases
nocturne matinal des oppositions son
rôle s'il a concédé deux défenseurs des
travaux ce matin il ya conseil des
ministres donc c'est plutôt non en tout
cas je trouve que cette façon qu'ont
parfois les oppositions de venir avec
des acteurs un peu comminatoire dû dire
on vient on convoque comme si on était
dans une convocation du jeune et je ne
sais quelle nature le polémiste me
convient pas lequel de mise en
application marc fesneau au 15 janvier
c'est-à-dire tournage et encore certains
objectifs j'étais assez heureux de voir
hier qu'avant avancer ces débats en fin
de soirée l'opposition la majorité
avaient trouvé un terrain de compromis
sur un amendement d'une députée
socialiste on va peut-être parler sur
l'enfant par les trois assassinats
l'ambiance on était capable de le faire
les débats reprendront cet après midi à
15h j'espère que la raison l'emportera
parce que le sujet c'est ce que j'ai dit
tout à l'heure le sujet c'est la
vaccination du maximum de français pour
éviter la situation dans laquelle on
pourrait se trouver alors les députés
avant cette interruption ont décidé de
restreindre un petit peu le pass
vaccinale pour les moins de 16 ans
finalement les ados qui ne sont pas
vaccinés pourront continuer à produire
un test pour participer à certaines
activités périscolaires et
extrascolaires lesquels alors hein
c'était effectivement le passé
l'hypothèse de démarrage c'était parce
vaccinale transfert pas solitaire
transforme en passe vaccinale pour les
mineurs
l'atterrissage qu'on a eue hier c'est de
faire en sorte que dans les activités
scolaires et périscolaires on puisse
rester dans un pass sanitaires pour les
moins de 16 ans pourquoi pas ce que
c'est on voit bien que ça pouvait
entraver et à dire un test suffit pour
les adresses il est fille par exemple en
club un test sans abri alors oui c'est
le bleu le ministre vert en arrière a
dit aux banques qui prenait l'engagement
de regarder toutes les situations on
vous permettrait que ce soit pas dans la
loi parce que ça donne des rigidités
mais l'objectif la philosophie générale
c'est de ne pas priver les jeunes au
moment où ils sont parfois restés chez
eux ils n'ont pas pu avoir des activités
sportives n'ont pas pu avoir un certain
nombre d'activités
culturelles je pensais donc dans le
décret d'application mais olivier viron
a pris l'engagement devant les députés
hier était un engagement du gouvernement
un engagement de l'irrévérence est un
engagement de faire en sorte que le
maximum d'activités scolaires évidemment
et périscolaire je pense aux activités
sportives culturelles puissent avoir
lieu après le raid était clair qu'ils
préparent à vivre pour les ados n'ont
vacciné de 11 à 16 ans un test suffira
donc pour aller en club russe arrivant
j'ai pas pour aller au restaurant ou au
cinéma ça ça va être une discussion on
en a parlé d'ailleurs avec 6,6
l'intermédiaire la députée socialiste
16 ans il faut l'autorisation papa maman
pour se faire vacciner bah oui et puis
quand vrai et comment on fait dans un
restaurant et comment vous demander aux
restaurateurs vous avez un jeune nous
dit-il à 15000 à 16 et comment vous
faites pour savoir si la 15e place à
vous contrôler voilà est-ce que et on
nous avait dit dans d'autres débats et
toujours l'opposition qu'il fallait
arrêter de demander aux restaurateurs de
faire du contrôle donc on va regarder
sur la question a su région mais
l'objectif c'est pas là que je pense que
les 11-16 ans le sujet c'est pas qu'il
puisse aller au restaurant ou pas là il
ya des dispositions qui disent le sujet
des 11 16 ans et qu'ils puissent avoir
des activités scolaires périscolaires et
qu'ils soient pas privés des activités
je suis assez content l'atterrissage
qu'on a trouvé